[Musique]
comment vos papilles
tout est au beau entraîné un pari pas
quotidiennement
est venu pour les chez moi et celle de
petits voleurs qui vieillit bien j'ai
des bons d
non mais ça va pas dans les flocages
ravi d'avoir vu tantôt bonne journée le
car qui sème la terreur pour le
printemps 2010 ap les forces afin qu'il
dit c'est ça le pouvoir
et moi je vais tout bonne nouvelle pour
lui j'aime croire toi c'est vraiment
dommage
les héritiers des pouvoirs du 7 ans
jeune ta fausse ne connaîtra plus de
limite légale solide quoi tintin daniel
quiessu je suis placé
c'est complexe et s'initie le serpent de
couleur noire est ce que vous voyez en
anglais l'objectif nous sommes d'accord
[Musique]
unis on peut faire quelque chose de
grandiose
non non mais je suis un petit massage
cardiaque qui va vous permettre de
détourner bien bas m'explique quand les
limites encore la haye
la cnec se doit de continuer ouais moi
on a la gueule alto pour toi on passe
tout sur la gueule mais dans le respect
tous moi je sentais déjà mais alors
s'occupe du développement de l'édition
numérique
la ceo j'ai toujours l'impression dans
le monde de l'édition numérique c'est un
peu vu comme un diable vous êtes là pour
bousculer un peu les habitudes jusqu'au
bas ça c'est à vous de me le dire j'ai
eu alain iriart midi d'accord pour
savoir ça va plus il a l'air en forme
contente très en forme super pour le
manuscrit donc non je publierai pas
d'enjeu temps sec avait compris ça me
ferait plaisir dîner avec eux enfin je
te dis tu as refusé mon manuscrit
qu est ce que j -pd moite qu'est ce que
vous pensez de la polémique qui fait
rage autour de votre livre la question
c'est de savoir si leur mention de droit
de s'inspirer de personnes existantes
mais sur canal a fallu un peu les lignes
droites sait quelque chose
c'est une façon de se venger je n'aime
pas la façon dont tu parles des femmes s
kitchen il la traite comme un objet les
ventes s'effondrent c'est dingue les
gens lisent des livres sur smartphone
moi je dis pas sur tablettes parce que
c'est pas ton époque ce temps de merde
tu me trompe elana après pourquoi tu dis
ça c'est dans un couple désire c'est pas
le début la femme tous préfèrent vivre
dans les po crazy oisifs à l'hypocrisie
et on est marié depuis 20 ans
[Musique]
ce
car ils sont quelque chose moi j'ai pas
trop envie d'en parler ça avance tommy
gunn bien bien bien
on n'en saura pas plus non
[Musique]
je parle avec les animaux comprend salut
petit rayon de soleil comme ça naomi
qu'on fasse la corrida je vous donne 24
heures pour bart et chaque fois il se
remet à parler avec les animaux et à
chaque fois c'est la catastrophe
il n'est pas question que je déménage
paix sur pas plus mais toi ça bien dans
laquelle vais arrêter de parler aux
animaux sauvages monza j'aurais jamais
cru que ce serait si difficile de parler
les animaux peut parler à longueur de
journée si ça fait du bien
vous allez passer trois jours avec elle
quand son parc qui les plus
extraordinaires des eaux pour nous dans
un chien des spectateurs allez on y
parlera ppl ne me dis pas que c'est
arrivé de nouveau
tu es mon fils ap arabiya il ya des
animaux qui se font enlever nous allons
découvrir kessler d'animaux allait bien
votre commande est plein bienvenue dans
scoop il en faut faire attention à vous
maison
qu'est ce qu'elle a dit elle se perd que
tu en poste parce que tu n'as pas
changer de chaussettes depuis quoi
depuis cinq jours elle dit ça fait trois
jours à tout casser
dimanche sur city génération x bio ce
n'est pas tous les jours qu'on tient un
sujet en or
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une superproduction expo
[Musique]
c'est magnifique
l'innovation
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est l'esprit
[Musique]
l'île fantastique pas si fantastique
il est temps pour nous
[Musique]
plus qu'un biopic l'histoire de toute
une époque à la bonne vieille star et
dimanches à 20h40 my dinner vous hervé
inédit sur city génération et du bo
je pense qu'à ça
elle se plante tout près d'ici elle nous
observe là en ce moment
c'est vous le rhin ce qui je la police
c'est pourquoi je suis là
c'était pêche ou non en fait c'est quel
genre de livre qu'il écrit georges
stephen king je sais ce que vous faites
qu'est ce que tu crois savoir je vais
être très bien
[Musique]
cette rumeur du léopard j'aime après le
voir
on a retrouvé le corps de yann alan
gagne son corps est greffé
de partout
[Musique]
si je suis capable de faire une chose
pareille je crois même borne à toi aussi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quand je crois aux miracles
tu veux pas d'un mort-vivant partenaires
à dix ans avec vous je sens les ventes
ok
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tout ça
[Musique]
tout
oui là
ouais
vous présente ma femme colette vous avez
vous est un écrivain à l'appel tu as
épousé une petite paysanne sans le sou
ce sont deux poules j'ai eu une idée
remarquable
vous pourriez écrit pour moi les
histoires que vous m'avez racontais mes
années d'écolière oui ce serait mon
nouveau roman
je m'appelle claudine jab x continue
probablement jeu ni m'aurait pas est
déjà parvenu à faire de vous sont
maigres
c'est tous ces trous féminin plus de
piquant - littérature c'est le plus
grand succès que nous ayons connue à ce
jour
savez vous qu'il achète les jeunes
filles 1
c'est un phénomène le tout-paris dit que
ton mari et chez madame colette j'ai cru
comprendre que willy s'était inspiré de
vos années d'écolière en effet j'ai eu
le loisir d'apporter ma contribution
vous avez fait est très important
ces jeunes filles vous leur avez donné
une voix quelqu'un vous l'a dit
et n'est-il de l'apprendre par d'autres
vous rencontrez m'a suffi
il vous tourner autour la jalousie est
mal placée c'est sa femme qui
m'intéresse c'est trop risqué
depuis quand considères-tu le scandale
comme une chose à éviter
bonté divine mais que portait vollard
le nouveau claudine pourquoi ne pas le
publier sous l'eau donnant c'est hors de
question justement non sire le roman non
nous tenons quelque chose d'explosif
si la situation nous échappe nous
risquons de sombrer tous les deux
écrivez
tu fais du mal du mal et du mal et tu
crois qu'en proclamant que tous les
hommes le français se disent que tout
mes réflexions
mais ces motions où nous risquons tout
ça c'est dix mois
quand tu m'as trouvé je ne savais rien
[Musique]
tu m'as façonnés selon td
tu croyais que jamais je ne brisera mais
chaîne eh bien tu attends détruit des
brûlis
je m'appelle commerce
c'est la main qui tient la plume qui
écrit l'histoire